Speaker 1: Donald Trump is now claiming to be the
new Elvis during a bizarre Gong Show interview
with Real America's Voice. John Fredericks, Radio
Network. That's a lot. I don't know exactly what
that is. It's a lot of different things. Here is
Trump based on the popularity of the song that
features Trump benefiting the January 6th rioters.
Trump says he's almost like the new Elvis.
Speaker 2: Thanks for being here. I want to ask
you whether I should call you Mr. President or I
saw you on HANNITY the other night saying,
You're the new Elvis. I help put that song
together. Justice for all. How does it feel
to be number one on the Billboard chart, sir?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: Well, you know who are J six prisoners?
They're number one because they asked me if I
do that and the money goes to them. And it's
a beautiful thing. And it was number one on every
chart, including Billboard. It was it started off
on iTunes and it went to Amazon. And Trump.
Speaker 1: Really sounds like he knows
what those things are.
Speaker 3: Doesn't it?
It hit billboard. That's the big. Number two is
Taylor Swift. And number three was Miley Cyrus.
Speaker 1: Molly. Molly. I was.
Speaker 3: Very honored. Maybe I'm the new Elvis
we now have now that we've gone into show business
with The Apprentice and now we do this. We've
covered a lot of territory in our lives.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this dude's really weird.
I have to say, folks, that song benefits
the insurrectionists. Think about that for a
moment. And then Trump really gets into the wacky
stuff here. He hits DeSantis again and says that
DeSantis bubble has already popped and.
Speaker 3: He was out of politics. If I
didn't endorse him, he was so far down, I
endorsed him and he became a rocket ship.
Yeah. And then he said, Yeah, well, I don't want
to comment about running against Trump. I said,
Is that the way it works? Because
there's something about loyalty
that I like. You know, there is loyalty.
Speaker 1: Loyalty above all else trumps
loyalty. No one but everyone must be loyal to him.
Speaker 3: I like it. Maybe I like it too much.
But the fact is that, yeah, he's his. His
bubble is popped, I believe. But. But,
you know, you never know. You never
know. You got to be careful. Yep.
Speaker 1: Could be popped like a balloon. And
then maybe most tragically. When the Nashville,
Tennessee school shooting was brought up to Donald
Trump. No, he didn't attack me like his son Don
Jr did. That's not what trump did, although I
was worried for a moment there. Trump's idea
is. Give guns to the teachers. Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Pardon me. They're saying that
this shooter went to another school first and saw
there was too much security. So then went to the
Christian school, which had less security. What
would you do as president to finally make sure
our children are safe and get trained? I mean,
there are retired military people. And Karen Shaw.
Speaker 4: I shared a video with you yesterday
saying we'll come forward, we'll protect our
people out there willing.
Speaker 1: To use life.
Speaker 2: Force, but retired
military. So go ahead, sir.
Speaker 3: There's that history of teachers that
are very good with guns because you really want
to where they can handle it. And you have teachers
that have a great, you know, record there in the
military and everything else and they're in the
school. And you can do that with ease, you know,
with it. You don't need a very big percentage.
You take the people that are really adept with
guns. A lot of people have been talking about
this concept I threw this out to. But you have
people that are very good with weapons and guns.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The same teachers who can't
choose which books the children are allowed to
read. They can't be trusted to choose the books.
The parents need to decide about the books. Those
are the teachers we're going to give the guns to.
And this is the solution that they're offering.
Speaker 3: That could be, you know, they're
right there on the spot and you could have
that. They can put them in safely someplace,
but very, very near I. And if you had something
like that happen, they take them out.
Speaker 1: Truly pathetic. I mean, truly,
truly disturbing. So, as usual, I mean, listen,
guys, we're now five days out from the shooting.
As usual. There is no serious conversation being
had about doing something about gun safety. In
fact, they're saying there should be more guns.
And by the way, if you suggest that prayers don't
prevent shootings, you become the focus, as I did
for the last week. The tragic reality of this is.
It makes sense. I'm kind of like struggling with
the right way to say is. It's logical if you've
been paying attention for the last 20 years since
Columbine. However, I mean, it's been longer. Even
if you've been paying attention for the last few
decades, it would be logical to say, I give up.
I don't think this is fixable. It doesn't seem
fixable because they don't want to do anything
about guns. The culture glorifies violence more
and more. Mental health may be a factor, but
they don't want to fund that. We have not. It's
done. We're just not going to be able to solve it.
And yet that doesn't square with
the fact that we have to solve it.
And many people, including those who are parents,
say we can't just give up. Right. Can we? Or do we
need to move to another country? But that's not
possible for so many people. So on the one hand,
it's logical that you would say, I give up.
There's no solution. But you also really
can't do that because what that means is we are
conceding it's just going to continue being like
this. And that's completely unacceptable. I don't
know where to go next with it. Let me know your
thoughts. Leave a comment. Send an email. We will
follow up. Quick break. Back after this with much
more. And I want to hear from you as well. I know
many people have been itching to call in all week.